Today, I'm gonna take you on a mythical journey.
We're visiting Troy.
As the legend goes,...
...the ancient city of Troy was besieged for ten years without success.
Finally, the city was captured,...
...thanks to the warriors hidden in a huge wooden horse.
Homer made Troy immortal,...
...and Brad Pitt made it popular.
Can you imagine the thousands of heroes that once fought on this battlefield?
Troy is not just a historical site.
It's a mythical one as well.
While the horse is world-famous, the real deal in Troy is the ruins.
Over the last 5,000 years, the ancient city was destroyed and rebuilt...
...not once, not twice, but nine times.
So, what about the horse in the movie?
Well, that's in Turkey too,...
...a generous gift from Warner Brothers,...
...and you can find it right here in the city center.
Discover all this and more in Turkey, home of Troy.